we all saw the trailers secretariat and
thought one thing sequel hmm Secretariat
so secretary it's the story of a
housewife played by Diane Lane who
inherits her dad's farm and all his
horses which are bred for racing and
then a horse is born on the farm and
then in order to save the farm she
trains the horse to race a horse named
actually they call him big red but also
Secretariat and of course the odds are
vastly against her and her horse but
she's determined she's shooting to win
the Triple Crown and with John Malkovich
as the horses trainer and Lafayette from
True Blood is really supportive black
guy I think she's got a shot so what can
I say I honestly have a really soft spot
for these feel-good fight the odds and
come out ahead through trial by fire and
root for the little guy kind of movies
you know like Rudy iron will and Cool
Runnings yes I have a heart don't hold
it against me I mean I'm not gonna lie
there are situations in this movie where
most people would have just sold the
horse for glue with the guarantee of
saving the farm but not Diane Lane even
Diane Lane says fight the man a couple
of her we've gotta do it monologues
seemed a little forced but I mean I
can't walk out of this movie and say it
sucks I mean we all like rooting for the
underdogs to win at least I do and her
main competition in the movie he was
douche tastic enough I mean he was one
of those loud Italian types that hits
the table after every sentence let me
tell you something we will beat
Secretariat tomorrow I did not have
sexual relations with that woman
let me tell you something I love
Twilight Team Edward so you just want to
see him get taken down now my main
complaint about the movies that you know
the end race the one that it just all
comes down to it just didn't seem epic
enough I mean I know the movies based on
the true story so you can't rewrite
history or anything but I think in the
end race they should have had some of
that really epic choir type music you
know like the movie trailer music with
all the chanting or they should have
made it something like the end of Speed
Racer I wasn't a big fan of the movie
Speed Racer but you know the end race
when he's just in the zone it just
clicks in his head and he's just going
for it and he thinks back to previous
dialogue that he's had with people that
was epic no I'm not saying the horse
wins or loses I'm just saying win or
lose it just should have felt more epic
I should have gotten more goosebumps you
know like more cowbell but more
goosebumps I would definitely say that
this movie is worth watching no alcohol
fired and if you are a family person I'd
say you'd buy this movie even on blu-ray
that's right to ratings to demographics
one video like I said I wouldn't really
because this movie is my kind of movie
but every time I see a movie like this I
seem to like them so I should probably
watch more of them but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more